les a rencontrées.
- Ils restent parfois sur
les tablettes, leur contenu
n'intéresse pas toujours
le grand public et pourtant,
à raconter. Les livres de
la bibliothèque du Parlement,
c'est un peu comme ceux
d'arrière-banc" : on ne pense
pas toujours à les consulter.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les journalistes,
quand il y a le ministre,
il n'y a plus rien d'autres
quexexiste, alors que
ça ne devrait pas!
- Émilie Fosthahahahahahahahaha,
et Claire Isabelle,
qui représente Huntingdon,
toutes les deux pour la CAQ,
nous rencontrent ici.rsrsrsrsrss
longues études doctorales.
ÉMILIE FOSTERdédéputée de
Charlevoix-Côte-de-Beaupré
- C'est dur de rester
quand je vois tout ce qui
sese passe, en termes de malaise
démocratique, parce que moi,
c'est ma spéenenenenenenenenene.
Ma thèse de doctorat
portait là-dessus.
(applaudissements)
- Les deux sont maintenant
ni ligne de partie,
parce qu'elles quittent la
poliquque après un seul mandat.
Elles regrettent d'ailleurs
de le faire sans avoir achevé
tant attendue, abandonnée
par leur gouvernement,
faute de temps et parce que
- Moi, je pense qu'on a
du progrès à faire sur
les conditions qu'on offre
aux parlementaires.
- Ceauauauauauauauauauauauauauas
travaux parlementaires à 18 h.
La possibilité, aussi, pour
les députés proches aidants,
de s'absend'un an faisait aussie
des propositions.
(babillage)
- Avoir une garderie, égalements
mamans. J'en ai vu plein
pour qui ça aurait été tellement
utile. Ça chan i i i i i i i i s
que les horaires.
- Si on veut attirer
des gens de qualité
dans cet
je pense qu'il devra y avoir
discussion également
sur le salaire des élus
dans la prochaine législature.
Huntingdon
- Faut dire aux gens : si vous
voulez vous impliquer, bien,
c'est pas pour le salaire.
C'est vraiment parce qu'il y a
que vous voulez modifier.
- Karine Boivin-Roy!
(acclamations)
- Les partis ont beau multiplier
femmes, ils ne parviendront pas
à les garder longtemps avec
un salaire de base de 95 000 $
et des conditions difficilesPars
qui partent cette année,
les deux tiers sont des femmes.
Même si elles pren
de plus en plus leur place,
elles doivent encore prouver
qu'elles la méritent...onononone
des perceptions,
des choses aussi banales
que leur habillement.avavavavav,
j'ai un homme qui me dit :
"Bonjour, madame. Mais vous
portez la même robe que
la dernière fois?"
- C't t le premier commentaire
qu'on vous fait?
- Premier commentaire
Je me disais : est-ce qu'il
voulait me déstabilir r avant
de commencer mon débat?
- Elle a grandi su
mais dès le début,
des agricultrsrs de son comté
ont douté d'elle, parce que
c'est un
- "Mais qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
d'une ofof d'université?"
- Être une femme en politique,
ça veut dire se faire direroror.
Parce qu'il reste encore,
jeje m'excuse de l'expression,
des vieux machos.
J'ai déjà reçu, même en privé,
des messages sur Messenger de
photos osées. J'ai déjà reçu ça,
oui, oui! Des avanceslalalalala.
- D'autres l'ignoraient,
carrément, malgré ses 11 ans
d'implication à la CAQ.
qui sont tous des hommes,
puis un autre homme arrive,
ils lui serrent tous la main m i
j'j'existais pas.
Ça m'est arrivé, là!- J'ai passs
à m'expliquer, à explierer
mon parcours. Parce que souvent,
les gens, beaucoup d
m'abordaient de façon très
paternaliste. "Tu vrvrais
faire faire telle chose",
comme si j'y a
- Émilie déplore aussi
les commentaeses
à l'annonce de son départ.
- On se fait dire, quand oququqt
parce qu'on est tombée en amour.
Ce qui est plutôt difficile sur
l'orgeuil, mais on se fait diree
qu'un homme se ferait dire
unun commentaire comme ça?
- On dirait que lui part pour
un meilleur emploi, par exemeses
familiales, mais certainement
pas parce qu'il a trouvé
l'amour, vous comprenez.
- Réaction aussi étoaiaiaiaiaiaé
sa décision aux maires de son
comté, auprès de qui elle s'est
acharnée à faire ses preuves.
- Il y en a
là, jusqu'à la semaine dernière,
parce qu'on a eu une activité,
et j'ai été obligée de dire :
allez-vous me bouder longtemps
encore? Parce qu'on a
des dossiers à régler.EtEtEtEtE,
des dossiers. Quoi qu'en dis
leur ancienne collègue.
- Les députées plantes v
comme moi, ça a pas travaillé
fort depuis 2 ans, ça, là.
- Découragée par les perceptions
négatives, Claire a décidé
revaloriser le rôle du député.
- Moi, je me suis fait poser à
main
vous êtes ministre?" Non. Ah!
d déception! La voir,
la déception, chez les gens.
qu'il est méconnu, mais il est
substantiel et c'est du 24/7. La
charge qu'on porte, c'est 24/7.
- Malgré tout, les deuxegegegegé
d'avoir fait le saut.
- Souvent, on essaie un peu
de nous mettre dans un moule,çaa
pour tous les partis, mais c'est
important d'être authentique,
d'être soi et de foncer.onononoe
se réfère à ses livres pour
souligner les grands moments
de son histoire, mais peut-êtrer
davantage à ceux qu'on appelle
"les simples députés",
si elle veut réalisertrtrtrtrtr.
Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio-Canada, Québe